wir haben hier einmal eine fp3 maske von
der jetzt immer wieder sehr gerne
geredet wird und dass sie auch schwer zu
beschaffen sind aber tatsache ist dass
diese maske vom bürger überhaupt gar
nicht gebraucht wird
nebenbei gesagt auch gar nicht im
krankenhaus gebraucht wird das ist
nämlich eine atemschutzmaske gegen
feinstaub dies entwickelt worden für
handwerker die mit feinstäuben arbeiten
und die natürlich ihre lunge schützen so
etwas setzt man auf wenn man mit steuben
oder auch mit tat mit lack euro sollen
beim spritzen von fahrzeugen oder und
sowas arbeitet hier haben eine fb2 maske
dieses schon sehr viel leichter
angenehmer zu tragen wichtig immer hier
über soja und dann an rohren dann kann
man hier oben ist ein bügel ein
metallbügel ein drahtbügel richtig an
modellieren damit es hier wurde anliegt
und hier und dann kann ich jetzt aber
schon nicht mehr entziehen wenn ich oben
ziel geht oben weg das heißt also wenn
der kopf vielleicht etwas größer ist
oder wenn er zu klein ist dann zeigt das
trotzdem brand vorbei weil dein viel zu
viel sagt aber das ist natürlich eine
maske die in jede richtung als in beide
richtungen auch schutz bietet kann man
gut machen braucht man nicht unbedingt
wir haben gleich noch was besseres
die selbstgebauten masken die man sich
zu hause gut nähen kann mit der
nähmaschine oder auch mit der hand hier
ist wichtig dass wir einen vernünftigen
stoff haben die können also auch ist
aber entweder in die mikrofaser nehmen
oder wie zerschneiden ein altes t-shirt
legen von drei lagen übereinander und
machen sich dann noch die menschen ran
oder auch gummis und dann haben sie auch
in einen vernünftigen schutz in beide
richtungen ja denn dieser und
nasenschutz sorgt natürlich darf man
dafür dass die tröpfchen nicht heraus
fliegen und es sorgt auch dafür dass die
tröpfchen hier nicht zu mir in den mund
gelangen hat auch noch den ganz großen
vorteil sie können den mentalen schutz
zum reinigen bzw
zur virus inaktivierung in den kochtopf
liegen ja und lassen es 15 minuten lang
brodeln mit der mit der maske im topf
und danach sind alle coronaviren aber
auch alle anderen bakterien tod es kann
nichts mehr passieren
der kommt praktisch hygienisch
mikrobiologisch neu aus dem kochtopf
dann haben wir den chirurgische mund
nasen schutz
das ist ein mundschutz wie er
millionenfach von den ärzten getragen
wird auch vom pflegepersonal und die
trägt er eben auch an modelliert
nasenwurzel und zieht dann unter das
kind und sie sehen hier schon liegt
wirklich nicht an hier gibt es keine
lücken hier ist es zu oben ist es zu
natürlich muss man den nasen bibel auch
richtig an modellieren und und dann ist
man gesichert
dieser moderne schützt in beide
richtungen ist es praktisch nichts
weiter als eine wand eine mechanische
barriere die die tröpfchen auffängt
aufsaugt und damit bleiben auch die
viren im mund nasenschutz hängen und am
ende des tages oder wenn ich ihn
absetzen kann ich ihnen dann auch
diesmal nicht in den kochtopf sondern in
den backofen liegen den ich auf 80 grad
vorgeheizt habe und dann legt man ihn
für 30 minuten rein millionen von
operationen wurden damit gemacht
herztransplantationen
nierentransplantation wir würden niemals
mit solchen masken arbeiten jemanden das
herzland transplantieren oder die leber
wenn wir gefahr laufen müssten das damit
infektionen entstehen könnten das wäre
die empfehlung das ist die maske der
wahl